with your screenwriting van do you try
to be original or do you try to give the
audience what you think they would want
i think uh
i try to come up the original concept
and and uh you want to start out with
that and because that sort of what what
drives you i know you suppose i know
they say hey think about what what the
audience is they think about your
audience what's your genre who's
watching this who's doing that but i
think you start writing the story that
motivates you um
and and what gets you through you know
because you're gonna if you're gonna
have to live with this for a long time
in terms of like producing it or in
terms of writing it and then if you go
on to try to get it produced and made it
has to be um something that that
that you're proud of or that you want to
you know go through that
journey with so
um if that idea
is an original idea for you and
at least it's for me i start with that
so the scripts that i have
on written is is
is basically
um
from uh original thoughts and not i
don't even think about um the budget and
stuff like that maybe because
the stories i write just tend to you
know fall in the same thing but
you know it's not super high concept
it's not out in space it's not this it's
just like
grounded in in what's happening here in
humanity but but um
when i start out something like
i come it from a original perspective
do you think you could be okay with
being a writer for hire or something
where it may not be your
style and maybe two hand-holding of a of
a story
but you're being sort of like okay paid
to do it
even though it might not be something
you would want to watch would you have
trouble with that um
this is like me going through like if
i'm actually writing sticking to the
themes
my original thought of all this was to
have a sustainable career
so
to answer that yeah i would do it i'm
not a young buck coming out at 25 years
old and having the luxury of a lot of
time time and doing this but
i think the more you can do anything
the better you get get at it you know um
you know you always hear now i start to
understand
why
people might complain why actors take
certain roles and things like that
you know no one can everyone can't be
daniel day-lewis and do these
maybe you just want to
be a role that's goofy and fun
maybe i want to
test my chops on
something
different from i'm not you know we
talked about athletes and stuff
you want to come back to each season
with new things that you learn
everything you know whether if i ever
get a chance at a studio
world
writing something that's you know that
i'm going to learn something from that
you could always take that back and then
i could always do it as a hobby my own
stuff later you know that kind of stuff
so things like that i'm still not
opposed to that um
if if that is an opportunity uh
or you know i'm not one of those i'm
going to be not tour and everything
that's going to happen
um
i'm just trying to take it one one film
at a time if it happens uh the they'll
be i think that would be um
uh
a good problem to have to make that
decision
i always wonder about like actors who
get these commercials where they become
these spokespersons for like well over a
decade
and and
how do they feel about that i mean if it
provides a nice lifestyle for someone
and they feel a sense of satisfaction
maybe they weren't the leading role on
general hospital or something but
you know it's always but then some
people go to the sellout term
and i think that would be
i think most of us would probably
they'd go with the steady paycheck yeah
you know
we think percentage-wise of things and
me you want you know how many like you
said how many of us can can be paul
thomas anderson or quentin tarantino how
how many people are even behind the
scenes doing stuff that we don't even
know about that no one does that has to
punch up a script or do this or do
whatever you ha you have
but if you're in in it um
it
it beats um
other things so
like you know uh
you know definitely it would be
something it's now it's not like
something you always
want to do and like you want to build
leverage but also you want to be working
you know
nothing wrong with them no no no no not
that
how has all rhodes de perla changed your
writing process
i think
um since it's one of the earlier ones
and and and
and seeing
how it could be developed and into it um
i think now i'm trying to get tighter in
my storytelling um
you know you're trying to if again back
to an athlete uh analogy an athlete what
could you work on i think it's um for
writing for
uh
film i i need to be tighter for 90
minutes
um
for hours to perla
and other things i think there's a world
where you can have it like episodic
limited series so you could go
dive into the characters more you know
um and
uh
i think that's that's what i've kind of
learned if i have a if i have a
situation or an idea that involves tons
of characters
i probably would
start out writing it as a pilot
and
now if i have like a pretty
great
um idea that i could tell within
a film space of like 90 minutes
um
i'll switch to film i think that's
that's how
riding that all roads superior has
helped me kind of kind of divide
the two areas i believe
just to
keep them separate
because each one has its own sort of uh
you know um
format and
and expectations
when you say tighter do you mean that
you feel sometimes the story will
meander
and you're trying to keep it on course
yeah yeah i think um for me personally i
think because i write
very visually um
i think it's too flowery and i write as
a writer director
so
there's a lot of things i'm putting on
the page that that um
i don't need to
because i know i'm going to direct it
but i like to write it and create it for
for folks but if i was purely
writing as a writer i get a lot tighter
um because i i want to experience that
in terms of like
not to be you know
to explain things and not have as much
you know
camera direction or setting things up
and flowery i want it tighter so i won't
so i could turn the page
that would be my goal now before i think
the goal before was
writing something with with heart now i
think
maintaining that
but
but condensed
yeah
you